foundations is looking to be one of the
best core set products we've seen in a
very long time and one of the main
selling points of this set is that it's
filled with cards legal and standard
till at least
2029 now if this is the set to get both
new and old players back into standard
why is it that there are so many
non-standard legal cards as well as
having four different set symbols
throughout the foundation product line
let's try and clear up the confusion for
any new players watching standard is a
format of magic where you build a deck
of 60 cards and a 15 card sideboard
containing Magic's most recent sets as
of the recording of this video dominaria
United and everything released after
that is currently standard legal this of
course excludes the straight to Modern
or commander sets such as modern Horizon
3 and the Fallout Commander set if
you're still not sure Watson standard
head to Watson standard.com to find out
exactly what you're allowed to play
moving on to the set symbols starting
easy we have the main Foundation set
symbol any card with this symbol is a
core Foundation card it is standard
legal and can be found across all the
foundation product line which includes
play boosters collector boosters jump
start boosters the beginner box and the
starter collection speaking of the
starter collection we have our next set
symbol the foundation Commander symbol
this set symbol can only be found on
three cards and can only be found in the
starter collection you can find them on
Arcane signate soul ring and command
Tower and as you can probably guess
these are not standard legal they're
purely there as these three cards are
practically Auto includes in every
commander deck so it makes sense that
they appear in the starter collection a
wizard staff member has also confirmed
that these three cards come in their own
separate packaging in the starter
collection next we have the special
guest symbol there are nine new special
guest cards in foundations and all these
cards have a small chance of appearing
in both play and collector boosters now
here's the important part none of these
Foundation special guest cards are
currently standard legal out of all of
the 88 special guest cards that have
appeared in the past six sets only one
of them will become standard legal with
the launch of
Foundations the secluded Courtyard Bloom
borrow variant and finally we have our
last symbol and by far the most
confusing one the foundation jumpstart
or the jumpstart 2025 symbol the new
Jump Start set currently contains
779 cards and surprisingly only 91 of
those cards are going to be or are
current currently standard legal how can
you tell if they're standard legal or
not well unless you use something like
scryfall which tells you which format a
card is legal in or not there's no way
to know simply by looking at the card
and just to add to the confusion there
are some cards like Elvish Arch Druid
where there are two versions of them one
with the core Foundation symbol and one
with the jumpstart 2025 symbol there's
even Crossway troublemakers a card
previously found only in Commander
precon decks but has now found its way
into both jumpstart 2025 and the core
Foundation set making it standard legal
is this the first instance of a
commander only card being made standard
legal let me know in the comments down
below for a set that's meant to be a new
players entry to standard the Wizards
team sure haven't made things completely
easy but I hope at least I've been able
to clear up some of the confusion
so as always if you learned something be
sure to like the video and subscribe
because if you don't I'm going to cast
marauding blight priest then
bloodthirsty conqueror against you at
pre-release thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next one